[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome to the final live
session of trujillocon 2022. it's been
an exciting couple of days and my name
is valentin shugravi
i'm one of the general chairs of the
conference and it is my privilege to
introduce our last keynote speaker who
signed a tavara
hussein is a clinical pharmacologist
he's a
researcher in drug development currently
he's serving as head of clinical
pharmacology and pharmacometrics at
moderna and his research focuses on
developing predictive models to guide
clinical dose decisions for mlni
vaccines and therapeutics
and hussein at this i hand it over to
you
hi yes
sound check can you guys hear me okay
we can hear you yes okay awesome
okay and and the slides are visible
yep
okay
thanks uh thank you
[Music]
to all the organizations or organizers
for uh inviting here for this talk uh
it's a pleasure to be here and uh
share some of the
really cool things that we are doing
here at modern up to support uh
development of our vaccines and
therapeutics
yeah using modeling and simulation
so these are some forward-looking
statements
that we are going to make and
disclaimers so jumping in
so
what uh
my role here is at modernize that we i
head up the clinical pharmacology and
pharmacometrics department uh here
so we
do modeling from drug development using
modeling and simulation
uh so what is pharmacomatrix for those
who are not familiar pharmacometrics is
the science of intermitting and
describing pharmacology in a
quantitative fashion
so by pharmacology we mainly look into
pharmacokinetics and pharmacodynamics
pharmacokinetics is the mathematical
understanding of rate of absorption
distribution metabolism elimination of
the drug and its metabolites in simple
words
what uh body
does to the drug is pk
pharmacodynamics as you will hear more
and more in the talk is um
is the study of kinetics of
pharmacological response at different
drug dose or concentration in other
words once the drug is in the body what
are the effects of the drug on the body
and how long do they last what is the
relationship between those concentration
etc is pharmacodynamics
uh
looking at looking at it visually
so once a drug it is administered it
gets absorbed distributed
metabolized and eliminated from the body
when we collect blood samples at various
time points we see that concentrations
rise initially as it is absorbed reaches
a peak and then disappears from
circulation over time as it is
distributed or eliminated the
concentration at various sites in the
body
leads to effect and the relationship
between
the
effect and concentration is called
pharmacodynamics
now
once we combine peak and pd we get
a pkpd relationship where you can see
effect versus time uh and the
mathematical understanding of these uh
kinetics and dynamics over time course
is
what we describe
using different models in
using ordinal differential equations and
what not in pharmaco metrics yeah
so
why is it important
so pharmacomatrix plays an important
role at various stages of drug
development
during early phases modeling and
simulation helps in guiding due
selection for first in human studies
in phase one clinical study
pharmacometrics helps in understanding
those response exposure response and
exposure safety relationships
which helps in predicting those levels
for later phase studies
at the end of phase one or phase two
studies modeling and stimulation plays a
very important role
in selection of phase three dose doors
it is important
as safety and efficacy are linked to
dose and exposure
and as you can imagine if the dose is
too high it may show unintended adverse
events and if it is too low it can lead
to suboptimal efficacy
and indeed selection of the wrong dose
is one of the very top most reason of
why
many drugs fail in phase 3 studies
using molecule simulation uh we really
get help in predicting safety and
efficacy outcomes using prior data we're
going through various learn confirm and
predict cycles
uh
so once we have selected a phase three
dose we have conducted a phase trial
then at the face
at the end of phase three again modeling
and simulation plays a very important
role in understanding uh
covariate effects those exposure safety
relationships and what kind of dose and
needs to be taken for different
subpopulations and that ends up on the
drug label which is
on the drug lab approved drug label the
dose that you see
is backed by a lot of actual data and
the modeling and simulation that has
been done to support it
so in our talk today uh i will walk you
through three examples where we have
utilized modeling and simulation to
guide those optimize optimization at
various stages in drug development
and
before we jump into
our examples
let's uh briefly look at the workflow
and tools we use to achieve our
modelling simulation objectives
so
to
achieve what we saw in the previous
slide
as you can see that it spent across the
development life cycle of a drug from
early stages pre-clinical to clinic uh
to all the way to approval and post
approval uh
in general there are a lot of different
tools that are uh available and used to
do this kind of analysis so those
include like ncaa non-compartmental
analysis population pk pd analysis
pbpk models qsp models
uh i will not go through in detail of
what all of these are but to enable
dynamic drug development uh
and go through multiple cycles of model
creation validation iterative
simulations uh we need uh
tools that could enable that and
uh there are like variety of tools
available but there is not like one tool
that can do most of it or all of it
the pumas software within the julia
ecosystem provides one stop for all
sorts of pharmacometric analysis and
helps in accelerating model development
and simulation workflows
uh and it was important for us to have
such an innovative tool to keep up with
the pace and the speed that we
uh entered into and uh
execute those workflow for us
and uh as you can see this statement
from fda which which
says that modern form drug development
approaches are extremely important for
maximizing the probability of success
across different clinical studies and
there are a lot of examples where um
these approaches have become very useful
and
changed the course of drug development
into uh
success yeah
so to have a tool that is
acceptable by regulatory agencies
those tools needs to be robust validated
reproducible and
need to deliver results in time such
that we can make those decisions when
they are need when the need is to be
made
so after rigorous testing and validation
we engage pumas to uh
tailor all our modeling and simulation
needs for the mitt program and we
use it here at modern extensively
so uh
going through now the example is now
let's jump into uh the case studies uh
so first we will talk about mitd for
therapeutics where i will discuss uh how
we use it for first in human dose
selection and then we will go into
imaging for vaccines where uh we will
showcase how we have been using
modeling and simulation for our uh
vaccines phase three dose selection and
then do selection for pediatric
populations
so uh
going into the therapeutic side first
here i will
show
walk through the example where we had a
limit lipid nanoparticle which encoded
heavy and light chain of an antibody so
the lipid nanoparticle with mrna
encoding having a light chain of uh and
antibodies administered in vivo
animals
uh and then
this mrna expresses uh these functional
proteins and
functional antibodies secreted out of
the cell by
using mrna technology
so
at our end uh
uh when we were developing this model
when we only had non-clinical data the
objective was to understand red to human
uh
translation of pk and pda responses and
then to predict what uh the human
response would be based on the
translational understanding that we
gained while modeling those outcomes
and these are some of the data that we
had so we had uh data across various
those levels in red and nhp after ib
administration and we had pecan pd
readouts measured over time
so uh
what we know from
small molecules and antibodies is um
uh
that as we go in higher species the
rates uh different rates of metabolism
of absorption
elimination
they slow down why because if you look
at heart rate in
rats for example it's much faster than
in humans blood flow rates are much
faster than in humans so overall small
animals are
the systems are much faster than what
we have in humans and we then we
see that resulting concentration time
profiles that show that the elimination
profiles are slower as we go up in
humans so this is something called
principle of valorometric scaling that
as we go up in species the
time course of response lasts longer
due to that slowed metabolism and
overall
system
it this principle works very well for
small molecules and antibodies in most
cases there are exceptions but for in
for our case we wanted to see if this
applies to mrna apk as well
so we embarked on the journey
and
used our
data that were available to
build a
pkpd model so here this is a model
schematic where
we model it using compartmental models
each compartment is an ordinal
differential equation and the rates and
2 and 4
to and from different compartments are
modeled and parameterized using several
uh under understanding of physiology and
some of the parameter bounds that are
possible
so
uh top portion is apk model once there
is the concentration then we link it to
the pd response so the igg is the pd
response that we had with this
mrna 1944 and that is also linked via
this pkpd modeling framework
so now let's look into the data so here
uh
what is shown is
plasma mrna pk profiles over time in rat
and nhps and as you can see
uh the half-lives in rat and nhps are
different where rat we have a shorter
half-life and hp's we have a longer
half-life
and when we applied the uh
the principle of elemetric scaling uh in
the modeling framework uh
we can fit the data across both species
by uh
applying those exponents of
clearance and rates so
body weight based elementary scaling
described the mrna pk well in rats and
monkeys
then we looked into pd which for
antibodies it is well known that
valumetric scaling works quite well and
in this case uh
also
it worked beautifully where
uh
the observed data fitted quite well when
this principle was applied
so
once we
have a translational model and we can
describe some of the
interspecies differences using some of
the known principles that we have
we can then use that model to predict
what human response would be
so uh
we had
at the time the question was what those
should we select what those range should
be taken in the human clinical studies
and whether that dose
is going to lead to
concentrations that are deemed to be
effective in humans
so
we use
this translational approach extrapolated
to humans using the same elementary
principle uh and
predicted what the outcomes would be in
humans
so here this is the prediction across
three different rows level is point one
point three and point six the solid line
is the median prediction and uh the
shaded area is the prediction interval
and uh
based on this
and there are many more other
simulations done
uh and these are the doses that we ended
up selecting based on the model
simulations
um
and
one microgram per ml was the threshold
that we were targeting and we wanted to
see that those concentration lasts over
a certain period of time and we can see
here that at 0.3 meg per kilo they would
last at least up to four months
after a single dose
then we actually conducted the clinical
trial and we got the observed data and
now let's see how the observed data
overlaid with what we predicted a priori
using non-clinical
results
so as you can see here
observed data overlaid very well with
what we had predicted
at all three those levels we
uh were very happy to say this because
for this was the first time ever when uh
a
mrna based therapy was used to
produce antibodies right within an
individual so
it is our own body producing the
antibodies by administering mrna and we
got a very nice those dependent response
at these three dose levels
and it also was very exciting to see
that how the translational framework
that we had worked so well in this case
so
uh we are using this across many other
programs and each different modality
each
different target has its own uh
different uh considerations that we take
into account in predicting responses for
humans
so
in summary um
administration of mr in 1944 resulted in
those dependent increases and levels of
antibody against chickweed 24 in rats
nhps and humans
body weight based allomatic scaling of
pk and pd model parameters adequately
describe the observed pkpd profiles in
rat and hps
and those dependent pharmacology in
humans was adequately predicted from
preclinical species
now jumping on to uh
pharmacometrics for vaccines
so
uh
pharmacomatrix for therapeutics is very
widely used in biopharma industry
um there are many examples of uh stories
and success a lot of models out there
and this is something which is now an
expectation in therapeutic side of
things
for vaccines this was a brand new
chapter so right now if you pick some of
the books on pharmacometrics you will
not find a chapter on vaccines
uh so here at moderna we embarked into
developing these models
so that we can use a modeling and
simulation approaches to guide those
selection for vaccines as well
and especially in clinical development
dual selection setting where we could
influence
those decisions
so
what how we embark on the journey
so we set out to develop pharmacometric
models for our vaccines the model
describes the immune response stimulated
by a vaccine and the resulted immune
dynamics so we call the model
immunostimulate immunostimulation
immunodynamic model or isid model for
short
now let me walk you through the model
development
as with all pharmacometric model we have
to first understand the underlying
mechanism of the medicine
or in this case the vaccine
with vaccines we know that they
stimulate immune responses after each
vaccination
and
immune immune responses can be measured
in multiple ways
the most common and widely accepted
measurement of an immune response after
vaccination is measurement of the
neutralizing antibodies
here we are looking at a typical time
course of neutralizing antibody response
generated after vaccination
after each vaccine dose our body
generates an immune response by immune
stimulation which persists over a
certain period
in developing model we first set out to
mathematically describe the underlying
mechanisms of immune stimulation and
dynamics of this response so what are
these mechanisms and how do we represent
them mathematically
so
here this is a simplified conceptual
representation of mechanisms underlying
the generation of feudalizing antibody
response following vaccination
following the first waxing dose
naive b cells are activated to produce
antigen-specific antibody secreting
plasma cells some of those
activated b cells form memory b cells
which are enabled to activation upon
second vecting those
after the second waxing dose naive b
cells as well as memory b cells are
activated to produce antigen-specific
antibodies
these are the
underlying mechanisms but how do we
represent them mathematically
well there are a lot of mathematical
equations that uh need that were needed
to describe this we started out with
simple models and then
saw if the model was capturing the
observed data and what else
was needed to be included what are the
different functional forms that are
needed to describe these responses and
these are the sum and at the end we had
a model that had 10 differential
equations and 17 parameters to
adequately describe the time course and
stimulatory dynamic effects that were
said
now to understand all of these
differential equations i will need to
give you a walkthrough of each equation
what each parameter is
but
i will spare you the pain and not go
into all of those details details here
and i just wanted to show you that what
it looks behind the scenes
so here
why develop such a model and what is the
use
so the key questions that uh
were in front of us and there are many
questions that can be answered like what
what is the dose what is the regimen uh
what
and uh what are different correlated
effects but here we will focus on uh two
main questions so first one is what
vaccine dose should be used in clinical
studies and the second how do we select
doses for different age groups
for me personally the most important
question was
what vaccine doses should be given to my
six year six-month-old son and
two-year-old daughter
so it was a
very personal
thing and it is incredible that we
we had a chance to work on something
that our own children would get
so
the two examples that we will go through
are
here
so first one we will review the isid and
reactogenicity modeling for our cmv
vaccine
uh
and uh
i'll walk you through that first and
then we will uh go into isid modeling
for our mrna 1273 vaccine where we use
it for our pediatric dual selection
when we begin when we
we began developing these models back in
2019
we had phase one clinical data reader
from our cmv vaccine so our model the
development of these models began before
the pandemic when you know
code was not around so we started uh
way back then
and
since now we have these models we
were very nicely and readily able to use
it for our ko direction as well so what
is our cmv vaccine so our cmv vaccine
includes six mrnas that encode
uh two antigens five encode the pentamer
and sixth encode the gb uh antigen and
each antigen infects different cell
types
and we have developed icid models for
both antigens
we began
so
uh we began developing data with our
phase one uh data in hand so here
uh
we have we had data for neutralizing
antibodies against epithelial cell uh at
different those levels 30 90 180 300 at
different time points measured
and then we
wanted to see if we can
describe this using the mathematical
framework we had
and this is the data for our
antibody response against the gb antigen
uh so we had both of these data
and used this for developing our isid
model as well
so uh we went through a hundreds of
iterations to find the optimal model
structure parameters and then qualified
our isid model for neutralizing antibody
titles against epithelial cell infection
based on various numerical and visual
diagnostics
our final model describe the observed
data well here the dots are observed
data and solid line is fitted mean
tighter levels and shaded area
is the 5th to 95th percentile interval
as you can see the model had adequately
captured the central tendency of the
data as well as the inter individual
variability
we did a similar exercise for our
gb antigen data
and
were able to qualify the model
using different
numerical and predictive diagnostic
so once we have a qualified model we can
use it for performing clinical trial
simulations and answer some of the
questions that are at hand
the key question that we had in front of
us was
which dose should we select for our
phase three clinical study and as i
previously mentioned a selection of a
phase leaders is one of the most
important decisions during development
of a drug as it could
lead to
maximize the success tremendously if you
are
good at making those decisions
so
here we used our model to simulate
relationship between those and utilizing
antibody titles across a wide dose range
and evaluated which those is expected to
yield neutralizing antibody titers above
the benchmark of natural infection
in this plot here those is on x-axis and
neutralizing antibodies at one month
post third dose
on the y-axis
solid blue line is the geometric mean
titer and shaded area is fifth to
ninety-fifth percentage prediction
interval
we
we saw that a fifty microgram dose
was enough to achieve gmt above the gmt
benchmark of natural infection for both
epithelial and fiberglass cell infection
we could possibly get a greater response
if we went to 250 microgram where the
title exceed the benchmark in majority
of population for the neutralizing
antibody against fibroblast cell
infection
but those selection is not just about
efficacy we also take into consideration
safety
so
how about adverse uh
reaction uh at
those higher doses
so in order to model the relationship
between those and adverse reaction we
used a typical logistic regression model
here on the graph
we
have
at a given dose an individual may either
have no adverse events or they may
and we do this uh we collect data across
a variety of different adverse ones that
are there
and once that data is available we can
use it to derive a probability of
such events given a certain dose
and
once we have that kind of
probabilistic analysis done we can
derive something called a composite risk
or
composite risk score is a combined
probability of having any adverse
reaction
on the
slide you can see the composite risk
score on the y-axis and those on the
x-axis for each vector in those
composite risk score was modeled using
data from our phase one clinical study
probabilistic uh
modeling helps to produce a continuous
relationship between those and risk
of
adverse events
so wanna doses that are not evaluated in
the clinical study you can have those
continuous relationship build and you
can visualize that where are the
uh curves uh bending in a way that we do
not want them to bend and then we can
base our
decisions where
the
those risks are minimum
so now
if you look at
our 250 dollars 250 microgram those
which gave us really high
you can see that
the risks are slightly higher they are
not very high but
the
slightly higher risks of grade 3
reactions at 250.
if we dial down to those at 100 then the
risk of those grade three events which
and grade two grade one also
is low so
uh
it appeared that hundred microgram would
be a favorable dose from a safety
standpoint
now if we go back to our uh those
response relationship from the
efficacy side of things where
there is
where we see neurogenicity we can see
that
100 microgram those had a lower uh
had antibody titers that were
above the benchmark of natural infection
in majority of subjects
and
the basis of those selection is to
maximize immunogenicity while retaining
minimal risk of adverse reactions
so based on both safety modeling and
efficacy modeling
we selected a phase three doors uh of
hundred micrograms for a cmv program
this dose is now uh an approved dose uh
uh
for our phase free trial and our
facility successfully enrolling patients
in this study
at this dose
so
we
did all of this modeling and then
submitted all of this work
at different uh regulatory agencies
globally including u.s fda ema tga and
many other countries across the world
using the commerce software software
now we are switching gears to isid
modeling for our cov19 vaccine
here we will see how we successfully use
this modding approach for our pediatric
dose selection
the
for
uh
our covet vaccine at this time we had a
lot of data we had data available from
uh
2567 subjects
uh from our phase two clinical studies
in adults adults adolescents and older
children
uh which were
greater than six years of age uh and
from our phase three study in adults
the modeling approach allows for pooling
of data across different studies
and helps to derive inferences from
totality of clinical data
versus if we just look at observed data
and try to make our decisions then you
are looking at one set of data at a time
using a model you can integrate all
different studies and
get a
holistic understanding of our responses
in different age groups and then we
applied some of the
scaling
mechanisms that is there to
predict what doses would be in our
pediatric trial
so
how this was done we adapted our isid
modeling framework to develop that we
developed for cmv vaccine to cover it uh
and we optimized some of the parameters
that were specific to code 19.
we assessed those and ages covariates on
antibody title response and then
simulated antibody titers at various
doses across different age groups
so
what was our goal our goal was to
predict which dose level in young
children and infants would yield
neutralizing antibody titers that are
similar to young adults
on this graph the reference
immunogenicity data is from our phase 3
call study in young adults
and then we use our isid model to
simulate distribution of antibody titles
at different doses
uh and then we use it to evaluate we did
this for a lot of different those levels
and this was before
we
had our
we
did the actual pediatric study uh the
large trial
and
the
the real question was what kind of doses
will be effective if we have 100
microgram dose in adults what those
is going to yield similar antibody
response in
young population and for vaccines
this kind of modeling is
very new and
done for the first time yeah
so once we
have simulated this we compute a metric
called gmr which is geometric mean
ratio
and then there are some
set criteria which are accepted by the
regulators that
[Music]
meet the statistical criteria to either
pass or fail based on the
results that are
obtained so
uh using simulations we this these were
the results of our simulation back then
this was done in fall of last year
[Music]
where
we simulated at different doses 10 25 50
100
and then based on model simulations we
predicted that a primary series of 25
microgram was predicted to meet the
non-inferiority criteria in young
children and infants
we
as i said it was
back in august last year when observed
data in these age groups were not
available
the modern predictions were
useful in selecting
those is to evaluate in the clinical
study
now uh we have actual data
here uh that we got from our clinical
studies we actually conducted those
trials and got our data
and i'm extremely happy to share
that
what we predicted back then
in fall uh lined up with what we
uh
what the observed data showed uh when we
received those data
and
as you can see the observed data closely
correlates with model predictions
validating our modeling predictions and
the modeling approach
and shows that how
integrating the modeling and simulation
workflows during the clinical
development pipeline uh can help in
uh
sound decision making for or
do selections and can lead to
maximize the rate of success
so in summary
modeling and simulation helps drive data
driven decision making for clinical dose
selection
traditional pkpd models are widely used
for therapeutics
and we have adapted those traditional
pkpd models for two vaccines
isid models can be used to successfully
predict neutral and generalizing
antibody responses across various age
groups
and
our isid models can
predict a priori immunogenic responses
in various age groups
and we have demonstrated utility of
these models for phase three dose
selection for a cmv vaccine
in this case and
used this successfully for a pediatric
dual selection for a corey 19 vaccine
and
thank you everyone for um your attention
and listening to my talk uh modern our
pharmacometrics team is um
expanding we are hiring we have several
leadership roles in different
therapeutic areas this is just the
beginning for mrna medicines and mrna
science there's a lot more to be
learned done and
a lot more people to be helped
suffering from different variety of
conditions and diseases
so
we have different
apart from vaccines we have
autoimmune
therapeutic area there is oncology there
are a number of programs there and
there are rare diseases and we are also
building a qsp modeling function within
our pharmacometric
matrix group so if you or anyone you
know who has the skills
please go on our website and apply for
these positions yeah
and uh that's it uh
and
many thanks to our a lot of work has
been done in collaboration with our
pumas at ai team there
in particular vijay
has been one of the
key individuals who we have collaborated
with over
several years in
testing validating deploying the
pumas and also consulting for uh
clinical pharmacology and pharmacometric
leading to
some of the regulatory submissions and
yeah
so many thanks to
them and yeah that's it
thank you zayn um there are some
questions um one of them is um
what are the biggest challenges you're
facing with software tools when you do
these kinds of analyses
yeah so um
one is
the integration of different workflows
right so uh in when we think about
therapeutics um
let me just move this
here
yeah so different software soft uh for
different types of analysis we have
different software tools where
we go into those softwares do the
analysis then results from those
analysis are then imported into other
software tools that then do those
analysis and so we have to like keep
jumping between different uh
tools
uh that is one uh it is not a challenge
but they kind of hassle uh
people uh
but if something can do within a single
uh software then you know we would
prefer that uh
then other challenges like
these are software tools that are there
since
quite long time
and
[Music]
there has been
some
progress but not a lot of progress
so uh
like some of the time efficiencies and
things like that
uh
if you see a few seconds of increase uh
improvement in time on a small model
think about if you have a large model
and
that saves you maybe
one hour two hours and if you have to
run those models hundreds of times to
validate test
so
that is a challenge and if we have
something that is faster then we can
actually use that model to drive a
decision because decisions are timely
if we do not get our data models
predictions in time
then we are not able to uh
help
influence that decision because
decisions are to be made when the time
is in constrained
so yeah so that is the big one
thank you
um
there was one question do you have any
specific experiences within the teams
using julia before they came convinced
it was a good tool that made people go
okay this thing is cool we should use it
um so i was introduced to julia via
pumas so when pumas came along
and
me personally i was
intrigued by how everything else can be
integrated within a single workflow
especially the simulation workflows
uh some of the tools that we the
simulation workflows are very
time consuming and uh
here
in juliet is uh once you have a model it
is very easy to get into
those kind of things so
that is where what we intrigued
and then
it was a journey to test and validate uh
over time and we did that in record time
here uh yeah
um okay
moderna has been very successful in
applying julia based software to pkpd
modeling which other areas of track
discovery could you think do you think
could benefit from juria being used more
widely
um uh
so there could be applications across
all all sorts of uh
modeling right so this is ordinal
these ordinal differential equation
models are used in even
manufacturing like some of the reaction
systems that are there
there it can be applied
but again some of the
benefits and things like that will need
to be weighed there where how practical
is it to
jump from the current tool to a julia
tool
uh yeah if uh because those if those
models are not that complex and you know
the
gain in efficiency how big is it
so but but i i can certainly see that it
can it can be uh used there
uh then the computation is i think that
the other department is already using it
at modern
yeah
and maybe as the last question you
should models that worked well how often
does it happen that a predictive model
turns out to not be working once you
acquired and then verify the data
afterwards
so it is a continuous learn learn
confirm predict cycles so
uh it is not that one we create one
model and that's it model set then at
the end there is a
because if we go from
a very
uh
old or
model which is informed by very little
data and compare that with the final it
may it may not uh you know correlate so
the journey is to guide at every stage
so each at each stage there are
different questions so
for to answer a question this is the
model this is and we are able to
add that micro stage we are able to do
quite well in guiding that then once we
get more data we keep on updating so for
example our kovid model
where
we had that 2000 subject data that was a
lot of data that went into that model so
with that kind of data then
in more in uh
likely cases we are able to successful
as long as the model is good enough you
know uh tested validated in a way that
should be
uh the cases where it might fail is um
let's say
there is a preclinical model uh
which you base certain assumptions on
and you go into humans with certain
unknowns that how much is the receptor
density how is the
expression of certain targets within the
body that clear those
moieties and if those are off by
huge amounts
then your predictions will look uh not
very much aligned
um so that is where we do all kinds of
sensitivity analysis to see that hey uh
what kind of things uh
which parameters are important and if
they vary by certain extent then what
will happen here
thank you thank you for the insight for
talk and
i look forward what moderna does next
with julia
thank you
next let me welcome martin pravenberg he
is the vice president of engineering at
relational ai and he's here to give the
sponsor talk um of relation
welcome martin
all right thank you
um all right welcome everybody i hope
everybody is having a fantastic
conference i'm certainly enjoying like
the bread of material that's being
presented here it's all super super
interesting
um so yeah so in the next 15 minutes i'm
gonna briefly highlight what we do so
that you have some background on what
we're building as a product and then
i'll dive into how we're using julia uh
and what we're contributing to julia in
our product yeah
all right so first um so what relation i
is building uh the next generation
database system for intelligent data
apps based on relational knowledge
graphs it's kind of a mouthful so i will
explain a little bit examples what that
means exactly but it's important to
remember that at the core we're a
database system and we want to develop
intelligent data apps and it is
relational yeah so
list of the few of our target workloads
that we aim to support so that you kind
of have an idea of what you want to do
uh so that is reasoning i'll show some
examples graph analytics
json semi-structured data analytics
mathematical optimization and relational
relationship
okay and this is at the core built with
julia and i will highlight exactly later
uh which parts are in julia and how that
is working for us okay
um all right so to give you a quick
impression of what kind of things we
envisioned to build is like let's let's
imagine that we are going to build an
intelligent data app for flight data uh
so you all have used airplanes of course
you know there's flights they can get
delayed and there's historical
information there are busy airports and
so on so imagine that you want to do all
kinds of analytics over that where let's
say you want to know
which carriers have the biggest delays
or is there maybe in winter are the
delays longer or at the end of the day
are the delays longer you may want to do
some planning and optimization and so on
yeah
so how would you do that now
the ffa actually publishes data on
flight delays and this is an example of
that data inside a big query
and while this is great that we have the
data available it is really hard to work
with if you don't actually if you're not
human uh and if you're uh if you don't
know the schema uh like i pointed out
some problems with this data set is that
for example like here there's a caller's
flight time and there's a number there
but yeah what does that number mean is
it minutes is it hours is it seconds is
it something else
um
there
is some peculiar things like for example
if the flight is cancelled
then the flight time is zero so now
imagine that you're going to compute an
aggregate over this data set and you
forgot to exclude the cancelled flights
then you have some really quick flights
in there that are messing up your your
aggregates yeah so
generally the quality of models is
really problematic
and this makes it hard to work with and
write correct business logic
so what we do is that we
we allow you to define better models
so for example you can very easily
define that let's say
a heliport is a subset of airports with
certain properties
you can define that very clearly that
when a flight is cancelled you're not
working with strings let's say a string
y and you have to guess what that means
you can very clearly define a relation
of all the flights that are canceled and
then you can very clearly use those in
your queries and your business logic if
you're right over it
um you can turn data into data that is
unison metrics like for example an
arrival delay uh is the maximum of the
zero and the delta that we saw earlier
yeah
and we're going to say that as minutes
so now in the model we have very precise
information that is actually emitted
and you can do stuff like let's say
where you can work with coordinates of
airports where you can very precisely
use uh
the units of distance that you're
working with whether that is feet meters
or kilometers and you've all heard the
horror stories of things going wrong
when you're dealing with the wrong units
yeah so the language that you see here
is rel um so rel is in declarative query
language that is used by our system and
uh that is implemented in uh in julia
so to show you some examples that go
beyond modeling is you can add reasoning
in the system as well so for example
if x is located in t and t is located in
y then you can derive a new fact that
x is also located in y so that you can
compute transitivity you can compute the
distance between airports by using the
coordinate and a distance abstraction
that computes from the positions on
earth where
what exactly given the earth radius and
all the units of measurements what the
distance with those airports is that is
added to your model like imagine that it
shows up in your database let's say it's
a normal relation that you could query
and you can use that directly in your
business logic yeah
um we also really care about data
integrity so you can in the same
language you can define interactive
constraints that protect your data from
getting in a bad shape so you can for
example say is that if you have an
origin relation then it has to be a
relationship between flights and
airports
you can also say that a flight has to
have an origin you can't leave from
nowhere
you can say that in flight only has one
origin and for example you can say that
a cancelled flight cannot have a flight
duration and that a flight has to be
either cancelled or referred to or
arrived and not any kind of or a
combination of that okay
all right so this is just to give you a
very quick taste i didn't explain this
very well but it's just so that you have
a quick idea of what we do okay
now so this is the overall architecture
of our system uh our system is available
as a service um it is deployed in uh in
the cloud our databases are stored in
durable object storage like imagine s3
let's say
and then
we are running all the business logic
and the queries and
data loading and all that in transient
engines that we provision uh
that um use the scalable durable
topic starts yeah now in these engines
there is a database server process and
that database service process is
implemented with julia okay
now so on the client side we also have
sdks like just how you have let's say
you have sdks for amazon web services or
for database systems and all that
and one of those is the case that the
app is also virgilia and julia to us is
a tier one language where we have sdk
support for okay
um all right so i wanted to briefly
highlight like how we contribute to the
julia community so um
we have quite a history with the dealer
community we've been at many uh
juliacons like we were there in 2018 it
may be the first i'm not entirely sure
that this was the first day we were at
and there's many different packages that
we contribute to now so of course we
have our own uni sdk it's already great
that we have that
but we also open source new packages
that
we found key in the development of our
product so there's a package called
salsa that we use for incremental
computation that was presented at julia
con 2020
we had a package called blobs
that we use for the manual layout of our
data structures our b3s in the database
system that was presented at ulicon 2018
we have contributed to the performance
of fixed point decimals we use those
directly in our database like imagine a
decimal data type in sql that is
basically what this package is what we
use for our implementation decimals
uh recently we started sponsoring the
duckdb project
and
drb now has a library for julia and
dirk2b is an amazingly flexible awesome
sql system
and so thanks to our contributions there
uh julia now has an official package
that is sponsored by that that's
developed by the tokyo organization that
you can use and you can use that in data
frames this is independent of our
product yeah
now we've been uh uh
hiring over the last year a variety of
people that are core to the julia
engineering so some people that
contribute to julia
the language and the system itself and
some of the packaging ecosystem so
really one that many of you probably
know jacob quinn
he now works for us and he is full-time
working on things like improving http
libraries json libraries csv libraries
error libraries and so on
there's also in packets on the
development for protocol buffers there
is already a product of packets but it
is dynamic and not
highly performant we're developing a
version that is optimized for
performance that we'll hope to announce
that soon
and we are about to embark on a grpc
implementation if you're interested in
the rpc please reach out and maybe we
can collaborate on that
now because we use julia in production
with the database system which is maybe
a slightly different use case than many
of you are currently doing uh we have
all kinds of needs on monitoring and
production users that are kind of unique
to us and so we've also for example
developed a package called server
metrics that allows you to instrument
code bases to collect metrics very
conveniently and those metrics are then
submitted to datadork or prometheus that
package is open source and it was
developed by one of our colleagues dana
wilson
this year we have computed
we have contributed a memory allocation
profiler
uh nathan and pete presented that
earlier this week i'll have it on the
next slide i'll highlight it i will go
check out that talk
this is one of the tools that we needed
to better analyze the performance of our
system and we decided to help
make sure that the g-like community can
do this effectively
in julia 1-9 there is an interactive
treadmill feature upcoming
that was developed by kieran palnani and
various other people
and
what that allows you to do is to
schedule tasks that you really do not
want to be compromised by long-running
computations like what the problem that
we had for example is that in our
production environment there need to be
events submitted that the process is
healthy and metrics need to be submitted
into the system and all that um and
those tasks were not kind of scheduled
appropriately and so with interactive
deadpool you can make sure that these
are really really happening yeah
um and we are also embarking on helping
out with uh with garbage collection
performance and potentially integration
of mmtk uh there were various talks
about that this juliacon and we are
sponsoring the m tk project
all right so there are there are more
things that we do but these are probably
the highlights
um yeah so go check out the memory
allocator profiler talk if you haven't
seen that yet it's really cool uh so
what it can do now is that you can
profile which types are being allocated
what the call stacks are you can
visualize them with pprof it's available
by default in julia one eight
and uh thanks also to valentin for
helping a lot with this and peter nathan
from our site helped with that
okay uh all right i want to tell you a
little bit about the company to show you
like what is behind it so we are 170
people company now uh there are quite a
lot of people in there from very various
backgrounds that are very interesting
120 of those are computer and data
scientists
and 50 of those are primarily
writing julia full time basically that's
their primary job so we have 50 people
writing julia on a daily basis we now
have a five-person full-time junior
engineering team so those people are
developing packages for julia and
contributing to the dla system overall
uh our code base is 150 000 lines for
the core product
which is a fairly concise for a database
management system so we're happy with
that and then there is about 80 codes
80k floating around of other reusable
libraries that you could potentially
open source but that we're not ready for
yet in some cases
we have hundred thousand lines of julia
test suite codes and then in our own
language we have 32 000 lines of code
so
our system is in production we have an
automated ci cd pipeline that compiles
our julia code into binaries and deploys
that into our system every commit
triggers 27 hours of test cases
and in total we're running a thousand
hours of builds per day of course over
multiple machines holidays that wouldn't
work
and in a production deployment currently
we're executing 2500 transactions per
hour
we we expect this to grow very quickly
because our product is uh only like uh
deployed its first customers right now
and we expect this to tremendously grow
over the over the next year but it's
already interesting to see that there is
a live
julia system
that is uh processing about uh one
transaction per second in a production
environment
um
the the customers so like i said the
product is in production we have paying
enterprise customers i can't list them
but they're large and they have complex
business water problems typically
and we're also well funded uh we have
raised in total 122 million
this year we had a serious b of 75
million involving tiger global and
others
i want to briefly comment on what we see
next so like we think it's really
important to have foundational packages
available for systems like around let's
say protobuf supports erpc supports
parquet aero iceberg and so on that
stuff has to work really well and be
very efficient
and
there's already a lot of work done in
there but it it can still be improved uh
we also it would be great if there's
more and more uh high quality sdks
available
for cloud providers that we would use
and of course we will continue to invest
in anything that is needed for
production users of julia
we're also interested in performance a
lot in particular in scale up
performance as a scale up means that you
use bigger machines uh with
more cores and large amounts of memory
so we've observed that julia skills very
well in tight inner loops uh but if you
if your application does occasionally
allocate then the skill up performance
could be improved and we are engaged in
trying to make sure that that gets
better um
we're also really interested in static
analysis like for example what we
regularly observe is that let's say if
you have a code path that is error
handling if there's a book in that
codebot itself
then you will not see your error
handling and that's a big problem um and
so we're really really glad to see it
yet now in one eight and we're planning
to expand and that and maybe start
contributing to it
and then we're really interested in
improving dual interoperability like in
principle where servers and it doesn't
necessarily matter what the service is
implemented in which happens to be julia
um but it would be really great to have
also extensibility to julia within the
system um and so we are looking into
like how can we extend the system in
some way and currently this is often
done with wasm and javascript and all
that which is due to the sandboxing
capabilities that are there
all right that was it um the there's a
few much more elaborate talks available
online that came out in the last year if
you're really interested in the
technical details i would watch the cmu
talks in regulation ai
that dives much more into what we do
and then there's some other talks
available to give you more backgrounds
on applications and sort of the area
where we operate in
thank you very much
thank you martin um maybe time for one
quick question uh what is the thought
behind having your own in-house language
yeah that's interesting
it's hard to answer maybe join for the
panel as well that we have later um but
um like we need to write very expressive
business logic it's often highly uh
recursive so sql is not adequate for
that because of the recursive needs that
you have and also like the the it's
often like we have thousands and
thousands of different relations and
definitions involved so sql is not
designed for that kind of skill
um and we need a declarative language so
not necessarily julia
because we want to automatically
paralyze and distribute and optimize
that code and like while julia is
fantastic it's not necessarily great for
that
so that's sort of the short answer
thank you so much
it's now my pleasure to
invite jeff bezanson
jeff is a co-founder of the juilliard
language he's now adria computing and he
is going to give the state of the julia
2022 talk
thank you valentin uh can you hear me
okay
yes we can
great
uh all right well it's great to be here
uh talking to everyone and uh actually
that's uh thanks martin is that uh his
talk there is a pretty good segue into
this uh because he's also thinking about
you know where julia needs to go next
and where we are now
uh so this is a time we like to kind of
take stock
of the previous year and look at how the
language and ecosystem are doing overall
uh and maybe highlight some things
uh that are going on that people might
not otherwise be aware of
um so several uh julia contributors uh
also contributed to this talk
um
but i'm giving it so it's going to be a
little compiler heavy
hopefully unsurprisingly
so uh the last year was actually a
really big year for features um
you know we've been doing 1.x releases
for a couple years we have quite a few
of them
you'd think we've kind of gotten through
all the obvious features but we actually
hadn't uh and uh just this year uh a lot
of kind of big ticket
long-standing um or you could say
obvious kinds of features that we uh
that we never
had actually got done
uh
so for example uh you can declare a
field of a struct const uh and then you
can't modify it and you know that's good
for enforcing invariants and we can use
it to optimize
uh
so that's a nice feature uh and
similarly you can also declare fields at
atomic uh and you can also annotate
operations like increments and the
typical set of uh those kinds of
operations as atomic
for multi-threaded programming uh and
that might be science sounds a little
bit uh like a low-level detail uh but
it's actually very important because you
know we like to ask ourselves are there
any reasons
that you couldn't write some code in
julia you know is there any reason you'd
ever have to use c for example uh and
this was actually one of those uh
you know to do certain kinds of threaded
programming you need these operations um
and c exposes them and julia didn't so
we had to fix that and now you have that
in julia so you can do all kinds of
things like say writing a scheduler
for for tasks in julia itself
so that extends the range of the
language it's nice
type declarations on global variables
people have wanted it a long time we
have that now
nd array and concatenation syntax as
well
uh and the uh the news from the
left-hand side of the equals as it were
as we now have property destructuring in
addition to the usual uh positional uh
iteration based destructuring uh so you
can destructure by name uh and we also
have slurping in any position so you can
put the dot dot dot uh anywhere uh in
the argument list uh and collect say the
first and the middle and the last uh
elements
and there's also this nice try catch
else
where you can have a block that's
executed if there were no errors
so really a bunch of nice features just
in the last year
all right and there are a bunch of
compiler internals uh interesting things
going on as well so i've got a list here
to give a quick overview and then i'm
going to drill down and give some more
details on some of these uh
so
we added the ability to separate uh
ldlvm dependency
uh and native code compiler from the
runtime so that they become optional
and we also added the ability to strip
debug info metadata
and even the julia ir out of a built
system image so this is uh you know
something people want for shipping or
deploying applications uh they don't
want their dock strings and things like
that in in something that they uh they
ship to someone so now there's an option
to remove that
there's this very interesting project
static compiler.jl going on
there are improvements to pre-compiling
to address latency problems
and we have a couple
interesting new capabilities in the
compiler around effect analysis and
escape analysis i'm going to talk a bit
about
uh and we also added some early
finalizer insertion so if you have an
object
that has a finalizer and the compiler
can prove that it reaches the end of its
lifetime at a particular place uh the
compiler can now insert an eager
finalization call to free up resources
uh a lot faster
so that's really cool
and our lvm pass pipeline
has been improved a lot
uh and we in particular we've now we've
now enabled inductive range check
elimination
so we can automatically eliminate a lot
more bounce checks than we used to still
not all of them you know we'd like to be
able to automatically remove all the
bounce checks but that's very hard we
don't have all of them yet but at least
there's you know more we can do more
and that's just you know an ongoing
process
all right so just some more detail to
get a picture of some of this so
if you look at the lib julia 1.7 runtime
uh it's about three megabytes uh but it
links to lib lvm which is over 60
megabytes that's why i've got it going
off the slide there because it's uh if
you do it to scale it doesn't fit on the
slide
um
and it's it's uh so it links to that so
it's a pretty heavy dependency to carry
around uh it's one of the reasons why if
you try to deploy
say julia's system image to run
somewhere it takes up so much space
that's one of the reasons um so what we
did now uh in 1.8
is there's a separate library lib julia
codegen that links to lvm
and lib julia only optionally links to
the cogen library so lib julia is now a
little less than three megabytes
but if you want to you can drop the lvm
and the cogen part
and you can do that actually by just
deleting them
and we will see on startup that they're
not there and we'll just try to we won't
use the compiler
so now that goes from you know almost 70
megabytes or so
to have a julia runtime
now you only strictly need
three megabytes
but of course you have to give up the
jit in order to do that but that's
possible in some cases
uh so static compiler.jl is kind of
another uh very different kind of
approach to
uh to the you know produce uh deployable
or small executables uh sort of problem
uh and speaking of which you know i
really liked
jeremy howard's keynote um and it just
so happens that um we have we've been
working on things leading towards you
know basically his his big ask which is
you know make it easy to build uh
executables that you can hand to someone
uh and so it's you know we happen to be
working on that so that's good news for
him uh hopefully
uh so this this project uh yeah it's a
different approach uh where basically
you can give it a function
uh in a type signature to compile it for
and it will attempt to emit a small
object file with just that code so like
in this case you get a you've got a dot
oh file that's uh 992 bytes uh to do fib
uh so this is a you know this is a kind
of a hack it's actually pretty cool it's
actually built on top of the same
infrastructure
that the gpu compiler uses
it's essentially like instead of uh you
know using the same kind of uh
rules and restrictions that things have
to be statically resolvable that you
need on the gpu but just targeting the
cpu instead
and so as such it does not support the
whole language so there are lots and
lots of things you can't do in this um
but i think over time it will
be able to support more of a language
so we're kind of tackling this problem
from both ends so in static compiler
hopefully
the coverage of what you can do
in the language will gradually increase
and then from the other end starting
with the full current runtime in
language we will gradually find ways to
to make it smaller and hopefully we'll
meet somewhere in the middle and we'll
just have the best of both of those
worlds so
follow along with that
uh pre-compilation so tim holy did a
bunch of work on this uh this year
so a problem we had in the past with uh
caching uh pre-compiled packages
uh is that for a given package this uh
this green package here uh we could only
cache uh specializations that it did of
its own methods
uh so if it called something in a
different package in in package b
um
we we would uh we would find out about
uh that method that specialization being
needed uh but we wouldn't be able to
save it uh with the code for uh package
a so
that limited the number of things that
we could save uh you know in the hopes
of reusing them when we reload and so uh
that has been fixed
so that method now turns green and so we
can save that
um
and this is the result this is from
tim's pr
uh so basically it shows that uh the
file sizes are a little bit bigger and
the package load times are a bit longer
sometimes uh because we're saving and
loading more stuff
but the latency is smaller so this is
the the ttft is the time to first task
and so that is uh with the orange and
green bars
that we can do now those are those are
lower so this is good progress uh it's
the direction things need to move in
of course we don't have the ability to
cache native code yet but that's the
obvious next step
and the good news is that if we can do
that that's really going to be a much
bigger
impact because the generating the native
code is the slowest step and it's the
one we're not caching yet so there's
still a lot of gains available there if
we can do that and hopefully maybe in
the next year that will happen
so inside the compiler there are some
nice new toys so we have this thing
called effect analysis
where we can basically deduce what kinds
of things a function does um so if we
can ask for uh infer effects
um of say plus of two ins so that's just
plus of ins is basically just a totally
pure function uh all it does is return
that value and nothing else observable
happens in any way so that's why these
things are all green so no no funny
business happening uh in in plus two
inch
but if we ask about sine uh it's also
mostly green but there's this one red n
so the n actually stands for no throw uh
so it's kind of a weird double negative
happening here where it's it's not no
throw uh which means it might throw an
exception
because uh sine of an infinite value
throws an exception
so
that's something we need to know about
so for instance you know if a call might
throw an exception that limits uh where
the optimizer can move it around because
we have to make sure we don't uh you
know remove an exception that's supposed
to happen
in a program uh
or then if you ask about something that
mutates likes like a set property uh we
see then that also has uh this e thing
which is basically means like a
mutation effect that someone else can
observe because someone else might have
a reference to this ref cell
so you might do something that's
observable outside
uh or then you have something like print
which is just uh well you know print
prints so that's a that's the classic
example of a side effect so that is just
that's just deep red
so this is really neat uh very accurate
information that our compiler has
that gives it a lot of freedom to
optimize more things
so for example
if we just did a simple uh 2.0 to the
integer for power
which is implemented in julia of course
like you know like basically all of our
math functions they're written in julia
itself
so in 1.8
if you did that
you'd see the code we generate still has
a call
to that the power function there uh even
though all the arguments are constant we
weren't able to prove that it's you know
safe to evaluate it and compile a time
and preserve the behavior of the program
but in 1.9 we can in fact do that so
on master
and in that version when it's released
we'll be able to remove that call and
just replace it with the constant result
because we can do that by just walking
through all the code
for power and confirming that there
aren't any side effects
and so it's safe to just reduce all of
that to a constant
another kind of less intuitive effect of
this kind of accurate information
is it actually lets us compile faster in
some cases
so this is kind of a pathological case
but this is an example where we're
generating code that basically calls
sign on a thousand different random
numbers
so it's not typical kind of code pattern
but this kind of thing actually does
come up
in cases like modeling toolkit
for instance where it's generating code
and you might have a big model that has
you know lots of constants throughout it
uh so that it can come up in in
generated code
uh and so what would happen in 1.8
when you compile this
we see that it takes actually 13 seconds
to run inference and the optimizer on it
because for every one of those constant
values we're basically trying to
propagate that constant through the sine
function and sort of figure out what
happens and see if we can optimize it uh
which we can we can optimize it but it's
a very laborious process of you know
going through uh the sine function every
time and you know and basically tracing
through all the execution just to
understand what happens for that
constant value
but now we know we can just prove that
the sine function doesn't have any
effects
and for these arguments and so we know
it's safe to just call it at compile
time so instead of painstakingly tracing
through the code we know it's safe to
just call at compile time
and so we can just get those constant
values very quickly
and now this is i think
about a 200x speedup for this you know
admittedly kind of corner case but
it's very cool anyway
uh there are also some improvements to
inlining you can now put at inline on a
call site uh we can inline abstract uh
call sites uh we can handle some
combinations of some uh union cases and
constants a little bit better so just a
couple nice uh improvements there
uh and there's still a lot to come so uh
we're still working on automatic
differentiation with the new
defractor.jl uh that's our latest
attempt at that that that work is still
ongoing actually it just sort of picked
up again just very recently
and we decided to kind of focus on that
first
and uh you know based on what that needs
maybe design a more thorough general
compiler plug-in system uh based on that
but it was kind of too much to wrap our
heads around to just to figure out you
know what the right plug-in system is
first so we're going to do ad first
and also okay parallel lvm compilation
is also getting pretty close a lot of
work has been done on that this year
so it's just on the on the cusp of maybe
uh you know happening which will
accelerate
our native code gen a lot
uh which would be that that's a it's a
big part of our latency so that would be
really helpful
um yeah these are better static
compilation um items like i was talking
about i mentioned caching native code
uh and still at the back of my mind is a
kind of separate compilation model uh
for the language uh which would uh you
know let us do things behave a little
bit more like a you know c or c plus
plus kind of language
i don't have time to go into a lot of
details but just to uh you know if
you're interested in that it continues
to be at the back of my mind but we
haven't really done anything about it
yet
uh
all right so let's check in on
threading so this is a copy of the slide
from last year where we've got uh you
know things we want to do
on the threading system and we've got
some you know some in the green states
some in the yellow state
and so let's just check in and uh if you
can watch uh what watch let's watch the
check mark switch
okay so some things turn green
uh i added an item
um
some things turned yellow so there is
some progress here uh it's maybe not
quite as much as i would like uh it's a
little frustrating we still haven't done
some of these things uh but we we did do
a really good handful of things
and in particular i had to add an item
here this foreign thread support it's
under the performance column but i just
didn't have any space in the other
column it should be in the other column
so
that's a cool new feature and this this
is what it looks like so we had this
problem
where if you embed julia in a c or c
plus or java
program
and you that that program creates a
thread and then tries to call julia it
just crashes
because we expect to have certain thread
local state set up on every thread
so if we're running on a thread started
by someone else the state's not there
and it just crashes
so that's really bad
and but fortunately
starting in 1.9 this will be fixed and
we'll actually if you call into the
julia runtime
from some other thread we will we can
detect that situation we see that the
thread state is not set up and we set it
up and we add the thread to the system
and actually the number of threads
available grows and we just basically
add that to our pool as long as it's
executing inside the julia runtime
so now that just works so you can have a
multi-threaded native application
calling multi-threaded julia
and get scalability and and it works so
this is really cool
this is another thing a lot some people
uh you know people who use julia uh in
embedded kind of way uh have asked for
this for a long time as well it was
really really nice to finally have
and uh another
issue that people hit with threads and
uh this this was alluded to uh in the
previous talk from relational ai
uh is this issue of uh latency sensitive
tasks so we can you know julia's
currently mostly optimized for
throughput so if you have enough compute
to saturate uh all your cores we're
happy and we'll just do that um but if
you have something that needs to respond
to an i o event it's just gonna get
stuck at the back of the line so now we
have the ability to start a dedicated
interactive thread
that will only only run things that are
marked as being interactive
so that sort of solves that problem for
now
i think it's possible that we will
extend this model in the future to
basically just letting people start
their own threads for uh for interactive
items uh so we might we may switch to
doing it that way but at least for now
there is a solution in place
uh there's also been a lot of work on gc
this year uh i think if you look at the
julia con schedule i think there were
three
talks about gc at least uh which i think
is a record but it's uh
it's very nice to see and indeed there's
been a lot happening so here's one
example of some really good uh
performance tuning we've done
uh so there's one of one of several uh
gc performance issues 40644
this was a case where if you run
something repeatedly every time gc uses
you know 60 70 of execution time which
is really really unacceptable
um so
it's behaving a lot better now and now
we reach a steady state where it spends
very little time doing gc so that's nice
we added a heap size hint so if you have
a
if you feel like your julia process is
using too much memory
we will take a hint in the gc so it's
not a hard promise we can't uh you know
if you if you allocate more than this
we're gonna have to allocate it it won't
uh you know give an error or anything um
but uh you can at least hint to the gc
that hey please try to stay under uh
this size uh and we'll at least try to
do that um and
parallel marking so we can get better
scalability of the gc uh in
multi-threaded applications is really
really close so diogo has gotten that to
pull there's a pull request up it
basically works um yeah it's really
really close so i think that's going to
be merged very soon uh and we'll have a
nice uh parallel speed up in the gc and
also parallel sweeping uh which
christine flood is working on
uh that's also i think gonna happen
pretty soon uh and then we'll that'll
address some of the
multi-thread scaling problems we see in
the gc
uh and you can also see uh see eduardo's
talk about mmtk
which is really interesting and really
amazing that he's managed to hook up a
totally different garbage collector uh
to julia so this is a
you know interesting kind of
experimental thing that is you know this
could work out and we could end up with
the option to use a you know entirely
entirely different uh you know hopefully
much better garbage collector so really
huge amount of stuff happening in this
area right now
which is great because gc is something
we you know we didn't pay that much
attention to for you know a couple years
but it's happening now
a lot of good gpu support uh happening
uh this year there was a lot of work on
one api uh adding support for that and
uh
metal.jl is also uh coming along so
all these new backends falling into
place uh to use with the very nice gpu
support that we've got
uh and there was also a lot of work on
profiling this year
in fact this you know martin discussed
this as well pete and nathan put in this
allocation profiler and uh you know
sebastian is is amazing anytime someone
does any new kind of tooling thing it's
you know it's in vs code right away uh
it's really really cool
uh and there's thread and task aware cpu
profiling again also in vs code
uh and this neat feature where you can
profile already running code so
sometimes you run something but you
forgot to put at profile in front of it
so you can just hit a key
and we will get a signal
and tell us to collect a bit of a bit of
a profile
so that's really neat if you want to
just answer hey what's taking so long
you know what's it doing in there uh
neat feature
and we have package load timing so you
can do time imports uh and see you know
if your packages are taking too long to
load uh we can break that down and see
what's taking uh taking up all the load
time
more packaged stuff so we got a couple
nice um
package system features
uh so when you do package status it now
shows which ones can be upgraded
uh so you know what's uh you know which
ones might have new versions out there
and there's better support for working
with custom system images
uh and also oh man yes this is this is
one one of these big ticket uh features
you know i i've seen
many times especially uh people new to
julia would try to load a package and
they just get an error uh that it's not
found and then you have to tell them oh
you have to add it first you know and
i i don't know i don't know how many
times you know i told this to someone
and they just said well why doesn't it
just do that automatically for me and
why not indeed
so this is really common request that
now
thank goodness is finally finally landed
it will it will now prompt you to
install package if it's available and
you don't have it so you can just hit
enter and it'll just go through
so that's really nice
and this was you know you might wonder
why this took so long
you know there isn't a really good
reason but it's it was actually a little
bit tricky to figure out exactly how
this should work uh you know you don't
want to put too many hooks into you know
the language
to make like an interactive prompt
happen when you're loading a package you
know so it's a little tricky to work it
out it's so it's implemented entirely
inside the repple and it was just a
little bit fiddly to figure out you know
exactly what it should be based on
especially because the language supports
meta programming and that kind of thing
so you know how do you know what
qualifies as a using statement you know
so it's a little bit tricky so but we
you know we pick something that we think
works well uh but so it's finally done
uh and the number of registered packages
i think is pretty cool um we seem to
have had uh two doublings
in the past four years
so
i think this is really exciting i i
think this is pretty good growth um yeah
from
2000 and 2018
2020 4 000 and now
another two years later 8 000. we just
crossed 8 000 i think earlier this week
i believe
so this is really cool to see
uh so in terms of julia releases uh ian
butterworth put together this
interesting graph of how long is it
taking us uh between releases so we
originally intended uh to put out a
minor release
about every three or four months uh and
so we sort of did that initially
and noticed that's you know the releases
since 1.0 uh they are are coming out
more quickly than they did before that
time um
but uh we can see that it's creeping up
so
gradually each release has taken
generally a little bit longer to come
out and now we're creeping into the five
six-month
uh kind of territory um which is uh
not so great uh it's taking it is taking
longer than expected to stabilize
releases uh i mean i guess the good part
of that is is we really do take our time
to stabilize the releases and make sure
they work well um but it's taking longer
than anticipated
i think the a lot of the work that's
happening on our ci infrastructure uh
right now is gonna help with that uh
because it's it's got it's getting a lot
better um a lot of people have been
putting a lot of time into that um the
ci has been a you know a perennial kind
of problem for us and they're really
trying to get it right
uh and make it work really well and i
think that's quite close and it's
already it's already a lot better and
it's quite close to working very well
and i think that will help a little with
some of this um otherwise i'm i'm not
sure i mean um
yeah there's a little bit of a downtrend
here at the end of the graph so maybe
we're uh we're getting back to some
slightly quicker releases but uh yeah
this is this is what's been happening
and uh oh yeah this happened
so
we hit uh we hit 10 years
uh go check out this blog post uh if you
haven't seen it um but yeah this is um
in february we hit our 10 year
anniversary of the uh public release
and so uh
yeah we've been at this for ten years
i'm not sure what else to say but i'm
gonna i'm gonna end on that note uh yeah
please see this blog post there are many
nice uh remembrances and and comments
uh from many many many different uh
julia users
so uh yeah that's uh that's it for this
year i will try to take some questions
and thank you
thank you jeff
um so maybe one quick question um is 2.0
coming after 1.9
when what can we expect from 2.0 oh well
after 1.9 will be 1.10
yes
so there is no
what 2.0 plan
uh there's no date there's no
spec for it there really is no there's
no such plan in the works um if anyone
ever thinks of something that sounds
like a good idea but would be breaking
we just tag it 2.0 as an issue and
leave that for you know if and when that
happens
but as for me personally
uh of the things that i would like to
see i don't believe any of them really
require breaking changes i think
anything that i can see that i think we
need to do can be done in in one.x in a
you know not breaking away so i don't
see a need for 2.0 right now
thank you
and
um
so yeah i mean you answer this in your
talk um uh executables that one can just
create
it's going to be probably still a little
bit away um but yeah so it's actively
worked on
yeah it's so it's it's like just as uh
as jeremy howard said that it's uh you
know he suspects there are things going
on behind the scenes that are you know
moving towards that but it's not yet
visible to someone who just says you
know give me the one line i can run to
get the executable it hasn't reached
that uh that point yet but the but the
work is happening
i'm looking forward to that
um okay
um
i don't see any questions right now
uh thank you so much for giving the
state of the drea
talk i think it's something we're all
looking forward to every year
um thank you for all your work on julia
khan it's quite awesome
thank you
and with that
um i will go over to
giving the
closing remarks on juliocon 2022.
um
looking over the conference we had three
days full of talks roughly 124 lightning
talks 62 full talks
14 experiences 30 posters and seven
births of the feathers organized
um before
the primary
conference we always have our workshop
and mini symposia and this year we had
15 workshops over eight days
roughly counting we had about 8 000
online registrations
and as uh jeff just mentioned we
amusingly also have about eight thousand
packages
um
and uh
just today uh the julia github
repository hit fourth out
forty thousand github stars
so this is a picture that i exported
earlier today it's a little bit fuzzy
but this is the um amount of uh youtube
views we got over the conference and the
blue line is this year and the purple
line is last year so there's a little
bit of a downward trend i think that
might actually just be that after three
years of online conferences people are a
little bit tired of them um but
generally speaking we track in the chain
trajectory and uh the
oh you uh the
video output um is really one of the
important things of dreacon to showcase
and highlight the diversity in the
junior ecosystem
this is one of my favorite slides um at
the upper side here are all of the
submission we have received over the
time since we opened the call for
proposals on pre-talks up to the
deadline
and one can see that we are very just in
time community
um
and so most of the
submissions comment just before the
deadline most of them come on in on the
day of the deadline and um
uh
juliacon this year is last year uh was
co-located with jump death and so the
breakdown in tracks was roughly we had
about 30 jump death
talks and
about
300 ish
talks at julia con submitted
right so
now it is my pleasure to introduce tim
who is going to
present the junior community prize
tim you can't demute
and we can't hear you yet sorry
microphone is not yet working
nope
okay
so
due to technical difficulties um i will
present it
um
the community prize this year goes to
the documented rgl team for their work
over the many years undocumented gl its
ecosystem
and namely morton michel frederick and
mauro
the second community prize goes to
frames white for her many technical
social and educational contributions are
across the trio ecosystem
it is
way too much we couldn't list it all
and the third community prize this year
goes to shuhei kadowaki
for his work on jet.gl and his recent
work on the julia compiler and
improvements and jeff highlighted them
in the
state of the junior con
trigger talk as well
the community price has been represented
on behalf of professor ann edelman
professor tim holly and curtis vogt
i'm on a personal note we've been
organizing for the last couple of years
the junior con proceedings and i just
wanted to remind everybody that any
accepted speaker juliocon is eligible to
submit their work through the triocom
proceedings and if you want to learn
more there is an announcement on this
course and we also
you can visit our website to find out
how to submit
um
while you might think the conference is
over it is actually not as usual there
is a hackathon
on the weekend after juliocon
this saturday and sunday it is going to
happen on discord and gathertain and i
see the hackathon uh channel on discord
for more details they're going to be
some volunteers are putting together
topics that they would that they are
going to mentor and if you're interested
to work on any of that
just join try to coordinate with these
volunteers and have a fantastic time at
the hackathon
and now to the most important
announcement
julia con 2023 is hopefully going to
happen in person
um it is going to be hosted at mit in
cambridge um
and uh write down the dates right now
uh it's going to be between july 23rd to
28th
if you're interested in volunteering for
julia con please reach out to the
organizers at ruricon trueland.org
and with that
i
hope that you're going to enjoy the last
half day of drugacon that you're going
to join us tomorrow for the hackathon
and
that we see you next year
thank you so much